I'm Danny Dover faculty instructor for
simply learned the author of the
best-selling book SEO secrets I was the
lead SEO at a teen teen or active and I
was lead SEO - company called SEO Moz
today called Moz in general I'm
basically nerd about all things digital
marketing welcome to SEO foundations
let's be clear from the start search
engine optimization is very complex to
simplify this dizzying array of concepts
we will be identifying the three major
parties involved with search engine
optimization and describing how these
three players interact with each other
based on their incentives we will see
why users are only interested in the
most relevant search results and how
search engines strive to provide these
results then we will consider how search
engine optimizers those who practice SEO
work to influence search rankings
name the three major parties involved in
search engine optimization identify the
incentives of each party involved in SEO
explain how the incentives of various
parties shape the entire search
ecosystem list the pros and cons of SEO
compared to other digital marketing
disciplines hello everybody today we're
gonna start our exploration of SEO
foundations with a very nerdy idea the
best way to understand a complex field
of knowledge like SEO is to first
understand the incentives of the major
players so for SEO this turns out to be
very easy the major players of SEO our
users the humans around the world who
are using search engines every day
search engines themselves and us the SEO
s so let's start with the most important
of these it's the users these are made
up of the hundreds of millions of people
just like yourselves who use search
engines like Google every day these are
people in the United States they're
people abroad the people using English
the people all over the place
searching with texts with images with
videos all kinds of stuff all of these
are considered the users and they're
what drive SEO from the perspective of
search engine themselves and from SEO s
the people who practice the profession
alright let's dive into the meat of this
the search engines themselves search
engines are technologies owned by
technology companies the most common one
of this of course is Google Google's a
company based out of Mountain View
California
it's dominating the arena of search
right now and has been for a while but
it's not the only player in the game in
fact there's a lot of other important
players the other ones that are big in
the United States are Yahoo which you've
probably heard of because it's been
around for a long time and Bing which is
owned by Microsoft outside of the United
States there's some other search engines
that are also very important so first
and foremost we have badoo which is
enormous in market share in China you
also have Y and X which is gigantic in
Russia and you have Naver which is
important in South Korea in addition to
that you have very specific search
engines that do one thing very very well
so a great example this would be Wolfram
Alpha which works on computational
knowledge and complex mathematics now
the 3rd major player in this is my
favorite now I'm very biased because I
am an SEO and this is how I pay my bills
but I think this is the one that's most
exciting and the one that we're gonna be
talking about throughout this whole
course so SEO let's dive into that a
little bit it's an acronym and it's
actually a very confused
acronym because it means two different
things SEO stands for search engine
optimization which is the field and
search engine optimizer which is the
profession so if you remember that part
you're good to go because that's the
trickiest part of this opening of this
opening section in that you have to have
one acronym that means two things so
what does an SEO do well an SEO does a
lot of things and actually as we'll talk
about it's an increasing amount of roles
but the important thing to get out of
this is that an SEO FERC focuses on
influencing organic rankings in search
engines so they are not working on the
paid side they're working on everything
else that search engines like Google
provide now that we know the major
players in SEO let's look at what
incentivizes them by understanding their
incentives or understand what drives the
market so the first one that we have is
users now this is everybody your self
include in this this is the world's
population who's using the internet to
try to find information the incentive
for the users of the Internet is to find
the most relevant information they
possibly can on any topic that they can
at any time in any language so it's a
very very big goal but something that
search engines work towards trying to
solve so what incentivizes the search
engines exactly well it's two things
they're trying to provide the most
relevant results to users worldwide but
they're doing this in two ways through
organic results which they do not get
paid for they're things that they're
just they're going to provide so that
they can do a breadth of information and
there's ads which third parties are
paying for that he'll also have relevant
information so what is incentivizing the
search engines it's twofold they're
trying to attract a gigantic audience of
users with organic results and with the
ads by providing relevant information
and it's the money that they're getting
paid for with the ads this works really
really well for SEO SEO czar focusing
only on the organic side it's a
completely different profession working
on the PPC side but what's important for
SEO is to work on getting their
information or more often their clients
information to the top of search engines
so that their relevant information is
shown to the world's audience of
searchers now that we have the major
players identified and their incentives
let's look at this weird relationship we
have between them so you understand now
what's driving them but let's look a
little bit more into this so we have the
users who are just looking for relevant
information and quite frankly they don't
care where they get it from they just
want the best information
in this most convenient to them and
convenient largely means free for search
engines you have two things that they're
focusing on it's getting a worldwide
audience of searchers by providing the
most relevant information and they want
to provide ads so they can get paid and
be a profitable you also then have this
the SEO s who want to provide the
relevant information as long as it is
their clients information or their own
information so you have a bunch of
forces that are working together you
have these search engines who need the
SEO s to help organize information you
have the users who are driving the whole
system any of these search engines who
are kind of forming this core of it but
on a day to day level you'll see that
this relationship shifts a lot people
start particularly the search engines
and SEO work together one day and then
they'll fight a little bit the next day
and then it goes on and on and on and
keeps the profession very complex but
very interesting and most importantly
profitable whenever you're doing a deep
dive of an idea I find it's really
useful to first take a step back and
figure out where it fits into everything
else so when we're looking at this
remember the SEO is just one channel of
many there's many different aspects that
go into online marketing and SEO just
has its own unique pros and cons of that
so let's look at that right now or the
pros of SEO why is it better than other
marketing channels well the first one is
it tends to be less expensive than the
other channels you don't have to pay a
third party over and over again
necessarily like you do with PPC you
don't have to pay per like sending of an
email you don't have to pay in those
kinds of ways so you do pay the salary
of the SEO or you pay the Commission
based off of that but you don't have to
pay some third party where that money
just goes away the second part of this
is it tends to be long lasting so work
that you do on SEO at one point is going
to continue to pay dividends into the
future this is very different than
something like PPC or as soon as you
stop paying the bills it immediately
goes away and all the work you've done
stops having an impact SEO is not like
that it continues to go on potentially
years into the future after you've done
the initial work now what are the cons
of SEO well the first one is the biggest
one it's constantly changing SEO is all
over the place sometimes the best
practice will be true and sometimes the
best practice it will not be true and it
depends on context and depends on the
environment of what's happening in the
big the bigger ecosystem so that is that
is a difficult part of SEO is that is
always moving is constantly changing
the last one is especially with the head
terms
go into that a little bit more more in
the future it gets very very competitive
if you're targeting keywords that lots
of people are searching on and there's
lots of demand for and lots of people
try to target with the same thing you're
going to run into a very very
competitive environment more so than
most of the other online marketing
channels
users search engines and SEO czar the
major parties involved in the SEO
process incentives of the major players
users want the most relevant result
search engines want to make money from
advertisements SEO is want to show their
information to searchers each of the
incentives of the major players in SEO
interact with each other to create the
search market pros of SEO SEO was
relatively inexpensive and is long
lasting cons of SEO SEO is constantly
changing and is quite competitive
you